when we first unveiled the Roadster in
2007 yeah I mean it was just basically
starting a car company is crazy you're
going to lose all your money I was like
I think I probably will lose all my
money I agree like I thought it would be
successful I thought we had maybe a 10
chance of success so then people would
say you're it's going to fail and you're
going to lose lose everything I was like
yeah probably true yeah what else is new
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
Elon Musk and my take on his top 50
rules for success enjoy
I think just generally the the path to
leadership should not be through
um
you know basically MBA business school
situation it's it's like it should be
kind of work your way up do useful
things and
um
you know and there's there's been too
much of the somebody goes through a high
profile MBA school and then kind of
parachutes in as the as the leader but
they don't actually know how things work
um they they you know they could be good
at say PowerPoint presentations or
something like that and they can present
well but they don't actually know how
things work because they do not
um you know then
they parachute in instead of like
working the way out yeah yeah they never
went through an apprenticeship yeah it
was a better word yeah yeah there's so
they're they're kind of like just not
aware of what's really needed for uh you
know to make to make great products um
so I mean I don't want to trash NBA is
too much here and I actually do have a
dual undergrad Wharton undergrad and
physics
um at UPenn so
um you know so I have like you know it's
like I have direct exposure to to uh
um you know to business school and I
went you know to do undergraduate school
with with physics but
um and I was a teaching assistant for
two semesters and I graded mbas and uh
undergrads
um so
uh but I think it's just a little bit
too much like like if people look at MBA
school as like I want to parachute into
being the boss instead of earning it and
like I don't think that's that's good
what do you look for in the people you
hire especially the engineers
uh really just look for evidence of
exceptional ability
so it's not or at least aspirationally
like sometimes these things get messed
up in recruiting or the recruiting
filtering ends up being wrong like I
sometimes wonder with Tesla if Nikola
Tesla applied to Tesla would we even
give him an interview it's not clear you
know this guy came from like some weird
college and somewhere in Eastern Europe
it's got some odd mannerisms now we
don't know if we should give him an
interview like I worry that that's
actually what we do instead of like
right it should be like man this this
this kid's super smart what does he want
we'll pay him anything that should be
that should be the reaction if Nikola
Tesla applies you know so Tesla
um ironically but so I can tell you the
intent is we're looking for evidence of
exceptional ability uh and it really
doesn't matter if you went to graduate
high school or college or anything we're
just looking for evidence of exceptional
ability uh such that it would be a good
predictor for doing exceptional things
SpaceX is it going to be a business kind
of tourism in in orbit or is it uh more
a kind of plan B if things owners are
still not develop as well it's not
exactly a plan B
it's more that I think I think there's
two two aspects to this one is that we
want to have a future that is inspiring
and exciting
and what are the things that you find
inspiring and exciting about the future
I think one future where we are a space
bearing civilization and out there Among
the Stars I think that's every kid gets
excited about that you don't even need
to teach them
they just get it it's like instinctive
and so it's very important for us to
have reasons to like reasons to be
excited about life like when you wake up
in the morning it can't just be about
problems it's okay I know everyone in
this room deals with a lot of tough
problems
but you know it's got to be more than
that so you know I think a future where
you can say hey even if it's not you
there's going to be people out there
that can we can have a base on the moon
we're gonna have a you know a city on
Mars maybe go further moons of Jupiter
and everything
I think that's a very exciting future
free worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all of the
Lessons Learned in this video as well as
pull out our three favorite learnings
and quotes that will inspire you to
actually do something the worksheet will
also give you space to write down what
your key takeaways are and your specific
plan of action to make sure you're
getting results if you want the
worksheet design specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business I'll see you
there this was x.com as a precursor to
PayPal basically you merge with
confinity and it became PayPal major
success yeah so it worked out better
than we expected
um
yeah um
so yeah uh it's Infinity so initially
confetti and x.com started out with from
slightly different directions and it
converged to the same point
um with with x the thought was to create
a integrated set of financial services
um so that you could go to one place and
do all of your financial anything
um and and then as a feature we had the
ability to transfer money or Securities
or anything simply by entering entering
unique identifier so like a
your email address or phone number or
something like that
and uh when we demo the system the hard
stuff which was the integration of all
the financial services people would not
be interested in but they'd be really
interested in being able to transfer
money using an email address you know
that was actually quite easy
um and so we focused our energy on that
um and although it's easy in principle
it what gets really hard is is adding
um security while still keeping it easy
to use that yeah so because
you know it's like the woolly lemon
quote like why do people why do our
banks because that's where the money is
so a lot of people rub paper same reason
and and so you can you can dial up the
security to a really high level but then
you're going to make it very hard to use
um and and so that that was that was one
of the toughest things we wrestled with
you first have to say what what is the
goal
um and once you have what is the goal
you can then measure the various designs
against that goal
um if otherwise you're saying how are
you evaluating why is one design better
than another what's your goal it's got
to be a goal so the goal is get enough
tonnage to Mars to add enough people to
make Mars self-sustaining as quickly as
possible
so then you say okay let's back back out
the math on this
we're gonna need we're going to need a
lot of tonnage uh maybe
I don't know a hundred thousand tons
maybe a million tons
so you can't be faffing around with
these expandable Rockets they're a joke
the key to making things affordable is
is like designing is it's like design
and Technology improvements as well as
scale so if you think of like say
um phones
um like the very earliest like the
earliest cell phones like
I'm probably like dating myself here but
uh like the original Wall Street yeah
where the guys like walking down the
beach and he's got like the it's like on
a giant phone he's carrying in like a
briefcase and everything they're massive
like massive massive phone yeah and like
all it could do is phone yep yep um and
like had like 30 minutes of battery life
and that kind of thing
um now at that time uh in the absence of
Technology improvements like no amount
of money no amount of scale could have
made that phone affordable that's the a
lot of engineering iterations a lot of
design iterations
um
and we're probably I don't know on the
30th version of of a cell phone or um
and and with each successive design
iteration uh you can add more capability
you can design you can integrate more
things you figure out uh better ways to
produce it uh so it actually gets better
and cheaper but it's like it's like a
natural progression of any new
technology that it takes multiple
versions and a large volume in order to
make it affordable other car companies
just really want to Outsource Battery
Technology not even not even making the
like this battery module and sell but
they're they're obviously Outsourcing
the sales but even Outsourcing the
modules in the packs you know and it's
like they're really not thinking about
fundamental chemistry improvements and
so I should say a bit about like like
electric vehicles and and so sustainable
energy in general you know I said it was
it was pretty I think obvious to not
just me to me but to a lot of people
even go back 30 years or longer that we
must have uh a sustainable energy
solution in fact it's sort of logical if
it's if it's if it's not sustainable we
must at some point find an alternative
to it and so even if there were no
environmental impact to uh the sort of a
fossil fuel economy then it would run
out of them and then we'd have economic
collapse and well civilization would
fall apart so so that that was actually
my initial motivation for electric
vehicles is like okay we've got to have
a solution that does not require
um mining hydrocarbons uh that that is
sustainable in the long term it was not
actually initially from an environmental
standpoint because I did not realize the
gravity of the environmental situation
at that time
um and I thought actually for sure by
now we'd have electric cars so we're
focused on exit it is important to have
that that have the objective be right
um as far as talking so much about the
importance of
making well Mars a self-sustaining
bullying self-sustain City on Mars
um if that's the objective then
obviously
you know just putting some satellites a
little bit or
is there's not that that's not important
you have to achieve full and Rapid
reusability amp size full and Rapid
reusability is only relevant to the
degree is rapid and complete
um
and uh and then you also have to do
orbital refilling this is essential as
well
um
and uh and then
um propound production on Mars also
essential so
uh
you know and with that as the goal then
you know that that means that that
creates I think a good forcing function
for radical Innovation because in the
absence of radical Innovation we have no
chance of meeting that goal
um whereas if I go simply
you know
defeat Lockheed and Boeing or something
like that that we would probably achieve
we've already done it
it really wasn't even a thing you know I
wish it was
um
yeah like they're they're not really
trying to do they're not even trying to
do reusability which is bizarre because
they make planes that are reusable
um so I mean if they if they talk to the
like you know if they talk to one of
their customers about buyers or a lucky
fighter jet or a Boeing aircraft like
Hey we're going to sell you a 737
computers once and it's and it's not 737
Max
um but that turns out that was something
that you start playing at times
um but it really uh it would be an
absurd thing for them to sell a
single-use aircraft but they feel quite
comfortable selling a single-use rocket
um and anyway but if I go with Subway
we're going to have be the leaders in uh
launching the conventional satellites
that exist we would probably
approach that in a sort of a logarithmic
basis where
you know you'd get there and you sort of
slowly made progress towards doing
10 launches a year 12 launches a year
and while they do six or something like
that um
but if since the goal is hey we need to
make life more defensive reports too
late
um and time really matters
so we're our states also it's like we're
shooting for Mars not just the moon it's
not much Soup for the moon shoot for
Mars
um and then and then the you know these
these competitive things are are kind of
small things along the way unless
somebody else is shooting from Mars they
will not be competitive with something
as uh pedestrian is launching a few
satellites into Earth orbit why is music
so important for you techno music in
particular
well it's pretty fun I think it's uh you
know you want to
I don't know feel maximum human
you know and uh
so I think when people have like sort of
a rave and good music it can be like hey
maximum human you know you want to
really feel
uh
you know it's like like what what really
gets you to feel you know and I think
that uh you know having fun with friends
and you know just
crazy crazy dancing is fun perhaps you
know techno music is the secret reason
why you uh are building big projects in
Berlin yeah honestly that's a it's a
significant factor Innovation comes from
questioning the way things have been
done before yeah um and if in the
education system you're taught not to do
that that will inhibit uh
entrepreneurship being able to question
what you you're being taught being able
to yeah I mean just you know saying well
is there a better way yeah
um you know to ask that question I think
that I've chosen have not been
um
I've not been trying to optimize on a
risk-adjusted return basis so there are
uh like I would not say that I went to
the rocket business of the car business
uh or the solo business thinking that
it's a it's a great opportunity I just
thought that
that something needed to be done in in
these industries in order to make a
difference
and that's why I did it so
um
but in general I do think it's worth
thinking about like what whether what
you're doing is going to result in
disruptive change or not if it's just
incremental it's unlikely to to be
something major
it's got to be something that's
substantially better than than what's
gone on before if you want to do
something really Innovative you have to
apply a sort of first principles
analysis not not and don't don't Reason
by analogy analogies are referencing the
past
um so first principles means you you
look at the most fundamental truths in
in a particular Arena
and the things that really are almost
indisputably correct and you reason up
from there to a conclusion and if you if
you see that that conclusion is that is
at odds with with what people generally
believe then you have an opportunity
now you can't operate like that on all
things because it takes too much mental
horsepower so mostly life you have to
operate by reasoning by analogy but if
you really want to invite you must
reason for first principles to identify
the problem if the output is more
valuable than the inputs which is really
that's that's profit like the upwards
more valuable than the input
that that says you have a useful company
um so but now in a high growth scenario
you have a lot more inputs for for
future outputs so that you have negative
cash flow and lack of profitability and
which we currently have a Tesla
um but in the long term of course that
has to be that that has to be fixed they
can't be negative cash flow in the long
term and that there needs to be
a net positive output
which is sort of profits in in the long
term but in the short term when there's
high growth that that doesn't it isn't
the most sensible I think it it is
definitely true that I mean maybe
they're occasionally companies that get
created where where there's not an
extended period of extreme pain
um but but I'm not aware of you know
very many of such instances yeah
um and um
so
but I do think that uh the the new great
entrepreneurs are born of every day
um and we'll continue to see amazing
companies get built
um so um
yeah but I but I I would uh definitely
advise people who are starting a company
to expect uh
a long period of quite High difficulty I
think that the way that we currently do
education is is wrong and and we're when
you see something like the Khan Academy
and so forth I think that's probably
going in the right direction I mean
generally you want education to be like
as close to a video game as possible
like a good video game like you do not
need to tell your kid to play video
games they will play video games on
autopilot all day so if you can make it
interactive and engaging
uh then then you can make education
far more compelling and far easier to do
so I think that's how it should be and
it shouldn't be that you've got like
these grades where people move in
lockstep and so everyone goes through
you know goes like normally you know
we'll go through English math uh
science and so forth from like fifth
grade to sixth grade to seventh grade
like it's an assembly line but but
people are not objects on an assembly
line that's a ridiculous notion
um people learn and are interested in
different things at different paces
so you really want to disconnect the
whole grade level three thing from the
subjects allow people to progress at the
fastest Pace that they can or are
interested in in each subject and you
want to make something beautiful I mean
you want to
trigger whatever whatever
fundamental aesthetic algorithms or like
like in your brain there's
you have I think some intrinsic
uh elements that that represent beauty
and and that that trigger
the emotion of appreciation of Beauty in
in your your mind
and I think that these are
these are actually relatively consistent
among people I mean not completely
um some people like me not Everyone
likes the same thing but there are
there's a lot of commonality and
and they're yeah and they're they're but
but I think it is important to con to
combine aesthetic design with
functionality like the thing that's like
if you say like what was really hard
about say the model S or the model X
um was to
combine Aesthetics and utility so to
balance the two you can make a car look
very good by giving it sort of certain
proportions like making it sort of low
and slim and and
um uh but if you uh if you do that the
utility is significantly affected how do
you keep your focus on the big picture
when you're constantly faced with if we
could be out of business in a month
well it's just a very small percentage
of mental energies on the on the big
picture like you know you know where
you're generally heading for
and and the actual path is going to be
some sort of zigzaggy thing in that
direction
um you try not to deviate too far from
the path that that you want to be on but
you're going to have to do that to some
degree
um
but I don't want to I don't want to
diminish the I mean I think the product
the profit motive is is a is a good one
if the rules of an industry are properly
set up so there's something
fundamentally wrong with profit in fact
Profit just means that
people are paying you more for the
whatever you're doing then you're
spending to create it
that's a good thing and if you're not if
that's not the case then you'll be out
of business and rightfully so
you're you're not adding enough value
and just in general critical thinking is
is good you know examining whether you
have the correct axioms or the most
applicable axioms uh does the logic
necessarily connect
um and then what are the what are the
range of probable outcomes outcomes are
usually not deterministic they're
they're they're a range and so you want
to figure out what those probabilities
are and make sure ideally that you're
the house
you know it's fine to take it's fine
it's fine to gamble as long as you're
the house yes you are celebrated your
30th birthday with a masked ball in
Venice for your 40th birthday I was told
you had a fight with a samurai sword
fighter what is your plan for your 15th
birthday next year
um well so my 40th birthday was the was
in Venice uh it was it was technically a
post-apocalyptic masked wall uh because
after the apocalypse how much clothing
do you really have you know
[Laughter]
okay it's not going to be a little
ragged a little burnt you know
um so um
no plans for the 50th
yeah
the half century party both
um I have to think of something
um
usually go with some kind of
crazy theme the the the the party where
I ended up
wrestling with the world champion tumor
wrestler which by the way also caused me
to boast a disc in my neck
so yeah five minutes of Glory for five
years of pain
um
it was that really hurt
um
uh so that party was
um
Victorian Japanese steampunk so that was
cool
uh I have to think of something for the
half century party you have a little
time to think living on Earth for a half
century that's okay I'm still alive wow
cool if you want to make something
beautiful I mean
that you wanted to
trigger whatever
fundamental aesthetic algorithms or like
like in your brain there's
you have I think some intrinsic
uh elements that that represent beauty
um and and that that trigger
the emotion of appreciation of Beauty in
in your your mind
um and I think that these are
these are actually relatively consistent
among people I mean not completely
um some people like me not Everyone
likes the same thing but there are
there's a lot of commonality but I think
it is important to con to combine
aesthetic design with functionality like
the thing that's like if you say like
what was really hard about say the model
S or the model X
um was to
combined Aesthetics and utility so to
balance the two you can make a car look
very good by giving it sort of certain
proportions like making it sort of low
and slim and and uh
but if you uh if you do that the utility
is significantly affected to make a
sports car look good is relatively easy
but to make a sedan look good or an SUV
look good is quite difficult really pay
attention to the little details
the the nuances of of design and shape
and form function and
um
that you know just the way it looks in
different lights and when something's
off the little thing how do you
experience that
never drives me bananas yeah
um I mean it's and it the the problem is
like if you you can train yourself to to
pay attention to the tiny details I
think almost anyone can
um although it it this is a very much
double-edged sword because then you see
all the little details
um and then little things drive you
crazy
um so but like most people don't they
don't see they don't consciously see the
small details but they they do
subconsciously see them like you you
sort of your mind takes inner Gestalt of
the overall
you know the an overall impression and
and you you know if something is
appealing or not even though you may not
be able to point out exactly why
um and it's it's a summation of these
many small details so most of us
experience it as a oh I think that's
ugly or I think that's beautiful or like
wow that's elegant but yeah can't break
it down
you mentioned something in passing like
you can train yourself in this though
yeah you can train yourself I think you
can make yourself
pay attention to to why
um you're essentially to bring the
the subconscious awareness into
conscious awareness
God I wish I could do that how do you do
that
just just pay really close attention
almost like a meditation on the object
I've been trying to find the details
like why do I not like this is that what
yeah just look look closely and
carefully the physics training is a very
good Training where it's a good
framework for reasoning where you're
trained to think about first principles
and reason from there and that means
boiling things down to the most
fundamental truths and then connecting
those truths in a way to try to
understand how a reality is because you
know physics has this problem where
they're trying to figure out things that
are totally counter-intuitive and so
they had to have a framework for for
getting there like quantum mechanics is
incredibly counter-intuitive but it's
true
um and so you had so physics developed a
framework for for figuring out things
that aren't obvious and that's why I
think it's it's what it's it's a lot of
advice but it's it's the right framework
you think about the future we want a
future is better than the past and and
so if we had something like the
hyperloop and that would be like cool
like you'd look forward to the day that
that was working yeah and I know
something like that even if it was only
even who only was in one place you know
from La San Francisco or New York to DC
or something like that then
um it would be cool enough that it would
be like a tourist attraction it would be
like a ride or something yeah so so even
if if
um some of the initial assumptions
didn't work out the economics didn't
didn't work out quite as one expected
it'd be like cool and I feel like I want
to Journey that place just to just to
write on that thing that would be pretty
cool
and so that's I think how if you come up
with a new technology it should feel
like that you should really like if
you're told to an objective person would
they look forward to the day that that
thing became available yeah and like you
know be pretty exciting to do something
like that
um or an aircraft like I thought it was
really disappointing when the when the
Concorde was taken out of commission and
there was no supersonic transport
available
um
and of course the 787 has had some
issues yeah
so
um but it's but the thing is the 787
even in the best case scenario is only a
slightly better version of the triple
seven yeah um
man it's like okay I'm not that exciting
I was just saying that you know you want
to take a moment to appreciate things in
life and the sensations
um food's incredible uh
and uh like there's just so many good
things that you can experience some of
them will cost nothing really
um you know have a walk in nature or
just a nice meal and it's like wow it
was pretty great you know and uh
we should take a moment to appreciate
these These Little Things the big things
um the things that move your heart I
think that's probably the meaning of
life was close definition as I could
think and just in general critical
thinking is is good you know examining
whether you have the correct axioms or
the most applicable axioms uh does the
logic necessarily connect
um and then what are the what are the
range of probable outcomes outcomes are
usually not deterministic they're
they're they're a range and so you want
to figure out what those probabilities
are and make sure ideally that you're at
the house
you know it's fine to take it's fine
it's fine to gamble as long as you're
the house I don't think everyone needs
to go you know try to solve like some
big big world changing problem I mean I
think that like if I I really think like
we should just think like are we doing
something that's useful
um to the world like if you're doing
something useful that's great yeah I
just think that like you're sort of a
usefulness optimization is is like
that's like a really good thing
um you know if you're if you've done
something that's useful to your fellow
human beings that's you've done a really
good thing
um and uh people should feel proud of
doing that
um you know it doesn't doesn't always
have to be something that's going to
change the world I mean sometimes the
world should just keep going in a
particular direction
um yeah it might be there might be going
the right direction and and I mean in a
lot of ways the world is and when we are
in
in great shape in that if you look at
say violent crimes
um you know
per capita in the world it's I don't
know like all-time low
um uh we're actually quite prosperous
and you know compared to in his history
um and um
you know I think there's a lot of things
to feel good about in terms of how the
world is today
access to information is incredible I
mean
anyone with like a 100 device could has
access to basically all the world's
information which is an incredible thing
um
and um yeah so I honestly I just think
like the best thing for people to try to
do is say like hey what is something
that I can do that would really be be
useful uh to the world and just do that
you know that's great first of all my
goal is not disruption for the sake of
disruption um I I really I think there's
okay there's some important things we
have to solve in order for the future to
be good yeah I would say like my you
know my sort of algorithm or
optimization is like okay what set of
things do we need to do uh to ensure
that the increase the probability of the
future is going to be good yeah and so
if we if we we have to solve sustainable
energy yeah this is totological if
you're not so sustainable energy then we
have unsustainable energy then it's just
a matter of time before things go before
civilization collapses we must but even
beside even if there was not an
environmental issue uh since the
availability of oil is limited yeah uh
this is not something we can sustain
long term yeah my original interest in
electric vehicles was actually not
environmental it was out of concern just
you know studying physics and I'm like
wait a second yeah we immediately
transition to uh solar electric yeah or
we're going to have a problem and and we
run out of oil civilization collapses
that's a problem now of course the
environmental concerns uh have added to
the urgency
um because the the more uh CRT CO2 we
put in the oceans and atmosphere the
more we increase the probability that uh
something will go wrong
um like I said like things are much more
probability as opposed to certainty but
I think it's an unwise experiment to
dramatically increase the CO2 yeah in
the atmosphere and oceans yeah
given that we know we need to transition
anyway because we ran out of oil yeah so
why run that experiment it's not it
doesn't make any sense
um we know we have to transition to a
sustainable energy economy
um then let's just get on with it yeah
you know let's just get on with it and
not run the crazy experiment and see if
that what happens if the atmosphere has
2000 PPM
CO2 this is crazy I wanted to Spur ideas
and thinking about uh the long-term need
to
um capture carbon
um and uh
you know I think this is one of those
things that's going to take a while to
figure out what the right solution is
and especially to figure out what what
the best economics are for uh for CO2
removal
um
and uh and and all the think through all
the consequences you don't want the cure
to be worse than the disease yeah uh so
uh you know sometimes people say we'll
just plant a bunch of trees I'm like
that's not so easy you know like like a
trillion trees
sure exactly and then you gotta like
okay well how you get fertilizer you're
gonna water them where's the water gonna
come from uh what habitat are you
potentially destroying where the trees
used to be it's not it's not just a
no-brainer if there's a plan about it
but it's not to say that's not a good
viable option we should plant some trees
I I I'm in favor of planting trees it's
just not a question of like Okay
um
you know there are like vast sections of
like like the Sahara Desert or or
uh the you know the some large Barren
areas very dry areas in the U.S
um where you couldn't plant a lot of
trees but you're going to need a lot of
water yeah and you're gonna be like like
you're gonna have to cultivate them it's
not like uh they don't just throw some
cheese in the ground
um drop them from orbit yeah and I mean
so just I think it'll be good to sort of
uh kind of frame the the frame the
debate and and understand okay what
things are really going to move the
needle how much are they going to move
the needle
um you know I
if we're talking about getting tens or
hundreds of billions of tons of carbon
in what form will that carbon be yeah
will it be stable over time
um and like I said like what is this
going to cost Humanity to do however
it's paid for what what is it going to
cost what's the thing that's uh gonna be
take the you know be most affordable
look for evidence of exceptional ability
so it's not or at least aspirationally
like sometimes these things get messed
up in recruiting or the recruiting
filtering ends up being wrong like I
sometimes wonder with Tesla if Nikola
Tesla applied to Tesla would we even
give them an interview it's not clear
you know this guy came from like some
weird College in somewhere in Eastern
Europe it's got some odd mannerisms now
we don't know if we should give him an
interview like I worry that that's
actually what we do instead of like
right it should be like man this this
this kid's super smart what does he want
we'll pay him anything that should that
should be the reaction if Nikola Tesla
applies you know so Tesla
um ironically but so I can tell you the
intent is we're looking for evidence of
exceptional ability uh and it really
doesn't matter if you went to graduate
high school or college or anything we're
just looking for evidence of exceptional
ability uh such that it would be a good
predictor for doing exceptional things
SpaceX I do think that it would be kind
of fun to do a cover of uh uh Bobby Gold
uh by Aqua you know that song Barbie
girl Barbie girl yeah Viagra I'm a
Barbie girl in a Barbie world
um plastic it's fantastic
everywhere
imagination so you know the lyrics yeah
I know the lyrics did you write it no
okay um but but I think it would be fun
to do a cover of Barbie girl but cyber
girl
cyber girl yeah in a cyber world we were
perfect yeah okay you you have to invest
in you it's fantastic in the future
there's no plastic you know that kind of
thing yeah I
don't I don't really like risk for
risk's sake or anything it's and I do
think that um
early things are are very risky uh with
a low chance of success but if you want
to try to come up with an inner
breakthrough that's kind of that's going
to be how it is
um
anything which is significantly
Innovative is going to come with a
significant risk of failure
and um but you know if you've got to
take big chances in order for the
potential for a big positive outcome
um and um
you know just if and if I mean if the
outcome is exciting enough then then
taking a big risk is worthwhile yeah
it's really our app portrait but but
then once executing down a path I
actually do my absolute best to reduce
uh risk you know because or to improve
another way of saying to improve the
probability of success because when you
try to do something that is very um very
risky uh
that you had you you have to spend a lot
of effort trying to reduce that risk as
you Embark down that path I mean when
um when I saw this SpaceX the I thought
the odds of success were very low
um I thought we're most likely fail but
I thought well
we should give it a try nonetheless I
think in general if you want to recruit
people that are you know really talented
and driven you have to say you have to
State what the what's the mission what's
the problem we're trying to solve and
and uh and just be clearly willing to
you know pour a lot of Blood Sweat and
Tears into it um and have a convincing
argument for why it matters
um you know there's you'll see like
there's three three major things for
um
you know in terms of motivation uh it's
like first of all somebody's got to look
forward to coming to work in the morning
like if they're like are they enjoying
the the work itself intrinsically
um that's very important
um
and uh
the right work environment can really
make make a big difference there I think
the idea is that they're also feel like
that their rewards will receive fair
financial compensation like that though
that you know that the financial rewards
are are are good and fair uh and then
third for the really for the best people
in the world that want to know are they
is what they're doing gonna matter yeah
like so uh if they spend 10 years doing
this it will make a difference to the
world or you know what people notice but
will it matter over time AI will make
jobs kind of pointless
probably the last job that will remain
will be doing writing AI software
and then eventually the AI will just
write its own software
so
I don't know I suppose I would recommend
studying engineering physics that kind
of thing
or working on something where
people just want to interact with other
people
and people enjoy fundamentally
interacting with other people so if
you're working on something that
involves people or engineering it's
probably
make a good approach
you know art of course
yeah
like I said I think
we're gonna have to figure out this
neural link situation
otherwise we will be left behind
um
it's very important we do this quickly
the reason I got into space was to try
to increase NASA's budget
well God bless you today
[Applause]
thank you
and but so I'll tell you so the
roundabout way I thought that might be
accomplished was
um I thought well if if NASA's budget
was more was larger than we could do
more in space exploration and I thought
well what what particularly if we could
get the public excited about sending
people to Mars and I thought well if I
could do a small greenhouse and and send
that to the surface of Mars with seasons
in nutrient gel and you hydrate the gel
and Landing you have a little miniature
greenhouse and then you you'd have the
public tends to get excited about
precedents and superlatives so it'll be
like the you know sort of first life on
Mars the furthest lives ever traveled
and you get people sort of excited about
well but where would you send people
there like the hell with plants we
should send people you know right right
um and um and then um I thought well
that could if if that could get the
public really excited about sending fuel
to Mars then that would translate into
Congressional support for a bigger NASA
budget that was the goal
um and then I didn't have enough money
to buy uh and I thought that that
outcome would have 100 chance of no
commercial success yes yes so the
harvesting a chance of losing all the
money so
um so compared to that SpaceX which I
thought maybe had a 10 chance of success
that was an improvement if you're trying
to convince the public to do something
you have to say okay how's this going to
read
um and what message are we going to try
to convey what will people respond to
what would I respond to if I was you
know sort of an objective member of the
public and um so that's that that's
really you know if you're trying to
change people's minds or get people
fired up about something then you got to
think okay what's that message what
what's going to get them really excited
I always uh I was always kind of like a
crazy kid I suppose um
I was just very curious about the world
and
um
how do we come to be here what's the
meaning of life and all that and uh
[Music]
I always had a really intense desire to
understand things and learn
um
yeah I mean I had sort of an existential
crisis I guess when I was on a
11 or 12 or something trying to figure
out what it's all about you know and uh
came to the conclusion that um
we don't really know the answer but uh
but if we increase the scope and scale
of civilization then we we have a much
better chance of understanding the
meaning of life and why we're here or
even what other right questions to ask
so therefore we should strive to expand
the scope and scale of consciousness
to better understand
the questions to ask about the answer
that is the Universe I would say it
try to learn as much as much
as possible that allows you to predict
the future or make the future say the
same is the best way to predict the
future is to make it
um
just and then assess whether what you're
learning is
enabling you to predict the future with
less error
are you less wrong
we're always wrong to some degree
but can you reduce the error on your
future predictions I think that's the
way to look at education
as of course but with both creative
create the future and predict the future
so that includes art and all those other
things
but close the loop on being less wrong
about future
I would say that's the right way to
think about education
I mean down the road with the neural
link
you can just upload any subject
instantly so we like the Matrix we want
to fly a helicopter no problem well
helicopters will fly themselves but you
know if you wanted to do whatever any
any given skill you just upload it
instantly
um and the way Education Works right now
it's extremely low bandwidth it's
extremely slow
lectures are the worst really it was
like very slow you know
um
yeah
just
try to predict the future with less
error this is the hard this is very hard
as you were saying I'm not sure it's
99.9 but it's it's not very good
generally a prediction of the future but
I think often people don't try the first
thing is try if you don't try okay
you know you've got to try and then and
then adjust based on the error of your
prior predictions it's hard to say
because things have worked out pretty
well in the end so how how big of a
mistake could it have been as the
question is really really asking
um
uh you know I did lots of dumb things in
my first company and at PayPal
um
and uh
you know I think I think sometimes
yeah but I don't know there's so many I
like I'm hard pressed to say this is
this is the biggest one you know give
this one or two
okay
um
okay sure um so there
the biggest mistake in general that I've
made and I'm trying to correct for that
is
uh to put too much of a waiting on
somebody's talent and not enough on
their personality
and I've made that mistake several times
in fact
then I would say actually I'm not going
to make that mistake again then I would
make it a game
um and and I think it actually matters
uh whether somebody has a good heart it
really does
and I've made I've made the mistake of
thinking that sometimes it's just about
the brain I think I'm kind of
constitutionally just geared to to just
keep going I don't know
um
it's a
yeah I mean it just I
I don't know I mean it certainly there
are times when
you know things don't go well and then
uh that's quite desperating for sure
um and so then it's it's difficult to
proceed with the same level of
enthusiasm but
um
but I do think like I do think the
things that we're doing are are you know
pretty important to the Future
um and if we don't succeed then you know
there's well there's there's not it's
not clear what other things would
succeed
um and if if we don't succeed then we'll
be certainly pointed to as a reason why
people shouldn't even try for these
things so I think it's important that we
do whatever is necessary to keep going
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
all right the whole reason I started
SpaceX was actually to try to increase
NASA's budget
um or at least the way I got interested
in space was uh I try to figure out why
we had not gone to Mars and and then I
thought well
uh maybe it's it we need to reignite
public excitement in Mars so I initially
started off with the idea of doing this
like philanthropic mission to send a
small Greenhouse to Mars to get the
public excited about setting life to
Mars yeah um and I forgot the public
excitement then they would tell their
representatives in Congress and to
increase NASA's budget what is the goal
but I was no actually it was meant to be
a philanthropic thing yeah um and I
tried I try to buy some icbms in Russia
to do this and ultimately came to the
conclusion that and that there's
actually plenty of will to to go beyond
Earth but there needs to be a way like
essentially NASA needs to have
um you know more affordable rockets that
we need to increase the pace of
innovation uh in space and so if we can
give NASA another horse in the stable
that that is moving faster and and cost
less and more Innovative then that would
be a way to accelerate progress in space
so I I love NASA and always have and
always will underneath your beautiful B
yeah it's crazy can you believe this
even is even here I was here a month ago
literally standing right here well not
just over the fence right and you know
he had a tube and a pointy tube yeah and
now you've got this I mean how do you
how do you do that is it just sheer will
is everyone that driven about the goal
I don't I think I've learned a lot of
lessons about how to make things go fast
um and then I've been uh
um propagated those lessons to the
SpaceX team and we there's just like an
incredibly talented hard-working team at
SpaceX
um in fact at times I think maybe
there's too many talented people at
SpaceX we're like
you know
too many times people that were
recording the markets was like
um you know but there's like it was very
talented group that works super hard and
uh
the and just have taking the general
approach of if if a design is taking too
long the design is wrong and therefore
the design must be modified right um to
accelerate progress one of the things I
think that might be quite important for
the future would be good and uh
obviously in order for the future to be
good we have to have sustainable energy
so we have to have sustainable
production consumption of energy so
uh that makes means making solar panels
low cost and making electric cars
peeling and then
we want to become multiple Planet
species in a space spring civilization
this is rockets and uh
and and then there's some things that I
thought will affect the future but I'm
not sure
if it's good or bad like AI
yeah this requires me that one one of
the most fundamental errors made in
advanced development is to stick to a
design even when it is very complicated
and to not strive to delete parts and
processes right right it's incredibly
important so this is why the swish the
steel was because the the advancedcon
fiber was taking too long it might be on
the on AI is essentially the you can
view the advancement of AI as solving
things with increasing numbers of
degrees of increasing degrees of freedom
so the the thing that the thing with the
most most degrees of freedom is reality
um but AI is steadily Advanced solving
things that have more and more degrees
of freedom
so obviously it's something like like
Checkers was very easy to solve that we
could solve with with classical uh
software classical Computing not really
all that challenging and in fact there
is a complete solution for Checkers
meaning it is literally literally
impossible every every version of
checkers is known
um so and then uh then then there's
chess which is also was also
um it had many many more degrees of
freedom than checkers
many orders maged here more than
checkers
but still really I would say a low order
of magnitude a low degree of Freedom
game
um then there's go which had many orders
of magnitude more degrees of freedom
than than chess so it's really just
stepping through orders of magnitude of
degrees of freedom this is the way to I
think view the advancement of
intelligence at Tesla we're like we're
just going to make electric cars that
are better than gasoline cars faster
yeah lower cost per millions they look
beautiful they're faster and they have
also you know cool advanced technology
they're more fun
um and you don't have to go to gas
stations which are nasty
and so you know but you got to solve
long distance problem with superchargers
so I think it is actually
you know uh gonna be way more palatable
to people if if it's uh if whatever
solution is is moving carbon does not
make their quality of life worse you're
also going to enable people to watch uh
like videos like streaming yeah through
the browser you'll be able to watch uh
like you know Netflix or whatever
um you know YouTube uh if it's if the
car is parked and connected to Wi-Fi so
if you're like say at a supercharger
station you want to watch something uh
that you can watch it on the screen in
the car but the general principle is
like how do we you know what can we do
to make the the car the most fun
possible
um and
um and like what would a car what other
cars just don't have you know and uh so
it seems like well you know it feels
like you're just parked somewhere
waiting for somebody
um finish an appointment or if you're on
a road trip uh be pretty cool if you
just like you know go to the car screen
and and play some like some fun game
um and um anyways exploring like you
know how do we make it as fun as
possible you can already play all of the
um you know old Atari games or almost
all the target games on the car
um and we hooked it up so I can connect
to Xbox or PS4 controller and like
actually have some a pretty good control
feedback
and then we have like uh genius moves
like the fart app
um it's my finest work okay
and and uh you know it's like there's um
you can actually make it by the way you
can make you can make the part sound
like it's coming from any seat
that actually is the funniest Easter egg
that one yeah and then actually the
names of the farts yeah there's the
Falcon heavy is one of them we've
actually spent
um a lot of effort on the spacesuit
design
um on the both the functionality and the
Aesthetics but I think just just getting
um it's actually really hard because if
you just sort of optimize functionality
it's one thing if you optimize for
Aesthetics it doesn't work
uh like you know those things that
haven't seen movies they don't work
so uh the the so it's like okay how do
we make something that looks cool and it
works
um
and um with with a key uh goal here of
being being that um you know when people
see that uh space suit they want them to
think yeah I want to wear that thing one
day yeah that looks awesome
um so that that's uh that's the reason
for it what I actually told you was like
everyone is a chief engineer this is
extremely important and that everyone
must um understand how the broadly
speaking all the systems in the vehicle
work right um and so that you so you
don't have subsystem optimization
because this is naturally what happens
you can see the organizational errors
um in the like the the product errors
reflect the organizational errors so it
like essentially you'll see that that
this an interface at at this like if
you've got whatever departments you've
got that will that will be where your
interfaces are right and then instead of
like getting rid of something or
questioning the constraint
the one department will Design to the
constraints of the other that the other
department has given them without
calling into question those constraints
and saying those constraints are wrong
and you should actually take the
approach that the the constraints that
you're given are guaranteed to be some
degree wrong guaranteed to be something
to go wrong huh because the the
Counterpoint would be that they're
perfect right which is never as you say
like what are the pro it's probably this
is a platonic idea or the perfect part
is zero zero okay basically so you could
question your constraints it does not
matter if the person handing you those
constraints well in Nobel Prize they'll
even Einstein was wrong some of the time
right so uh question your constraints
this is extremely important I probably
wouldn't have started programming if it
wasn't for video games uh or wouldn't
have been as interested in computers and
Technology if it wasn't for video games
I think actually video games are
um a very powerful for us for uh getting
you know kids interested in technology
it has way way bigger knock-on effects
than people may realize and and
generally like if uh we're interviewing
somebody for software engineering role
at uh
Tesla SpaceX
many times would be like how'd you start
programming it's like oh go to video
games you know over and over again and I
think many of the best software
engineers in the world are at uh at app
or or spent much of their career at uh
video games houses
um and you know especially if people had
to try to create incredibly realistic
Graphics uh using very little compute
power that's a hard problem and so a lot
of people had had to write really tight
code and come up with really clever
ideas to do that if you like someone
like say John Carmack uh you know who's
an amazing software engineer who's also
actually a really good aerospace
engineer and it shows like you know
problem solving I think does transfer
like you figure out
software engineering problem solving and
transfers to other things
I keep hearing you say we like it sounds
like you're always thinking of everybody
you're I see you as a very selfless
person uh thanks
I mean seriously I mean yeah it's like
from the age of 12 it sounds like you've
been thinking about how to help Humanity
um yeah I mean I I'm not trying to be
sort of like some you know
the sort of Savior or something like
that you know
but it's really just that
uh if
it just seems like the
it's just
I don't know seems like obvious thing to
do again like I'm not sure why I do
anything else
um
we want to maximize
happiness to the population and
propagate into the future as far as
possible and understand the nature of
reality
um and from that I think everything else
follows I think fully consider cost
actually it just means that if there are
um you want to look at both the benefits
and the the costs actually so if uh if
in um sequestering cop and removing it
from the atmosphere or oceans uh uh it
has has some uh perhaps some
environmental impact uh which might be
small but it's not negative that
certainly needs to be taken into account
um
and uh uh and then by the same token if
uh what's done is in extracting carbon
is a useful product from which you can
generate Revenue then that should count
two all right so I know I'm just sort of
saying for argument's sake like let's
say uh you could create
um
you know um construction material like
you know um cement cement yeah which we
just I'll talk about that later some
kind of useful rocks that are rocks that
are useful or sand or I don't know yeah
um something that's useful for
construction
um
then you could say okay well this is
what we could sell it for and uh
you know and then just fully consider
pros and cons and and and say okay this
is what you know if
um
if we need to pay to have it done in the
future which we probably will have to do
then
um what's the what's the lowest net cost
because you made
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to manifest success into your life
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there that's where
manifesting comes in manifesting is
preparing your mind body and spirit to
help you take the actions to get those
things that's right